PROFESSOR: OK.
Before we get started, I'd
like to deal with a small
matter of some unpleasantness.
The class is sort of like
a football game.
When there's two minutes to go,
you shoot off a pistol.
But when there are two meetings
to go until we have
the quiz, we shoot off a
pistol to wake you up.
We're scheduled to have
a quiz on October 6.
And even though October seems
far away when you're still in
September, that is going
to be a week
from this coming Thursday.
So if you have problems that
you're working on, try to get
them to me on Thursday, or just
come slide them under my
office door, if I'm not in.
And I'll have them back for you
on this coming Tuesday.
The way the material has played
out is that we're
really at a nice, convenient
juncture between one chunk of
interconnected material
moving on to another.
So I think the first quiz
we'll confine to
two-dimensional symmetry.
And beginning in about two
minutes flat, we'll begin to
move into--
take the first small steps,
at any rate, into
three-dimensional symmetries,
which will be much more
complicated in which we
will not deal with the
exhaustiveness that we have been
able to afford the luxury
of in two dimensions.
Before I begin, let me-- does
everybody remember their
spherical trigonometry?
Has anybody had spherical
trigonometry?
OK.
What I will then do is give a
short primer on some of the
definitions and concepts in
spherical trigonometry.
And then we shall immediately
use this to combine rotation
axes in space.
Pass those back.
AUDIENCE: I had a quick
question on this.
PROFESSOR: Oh, sure, please.
AUDIENCE: With the limiting
possible--
PROFESSOR: Yep.
AUDIENCE: --reflections and
conditions, that does say they
have to be figured out?
PROFESSOR: Actually, that was a
good question and something
that we are not going to use at
all in the symmetry tables.
Somebody asked what about this
notation in the far right-hand
edge of all of the
plane groups--
conditions limiting possible
reflections.
One usually doesn't put a
two-dimensional crystal in an
x-ray beam fairly often,
although I suppose a thin film
actually is almost a
two-dimensional crystal.
But you've probably all heard
one way or another about the
magic conditions relating the
Miller indices of a plane that
will require that the intensity
diffracted from that
set of planes is identically
zero.
And they're linear combinations
of H, K, and L.
And one of the rules is that if
H plus K plus L is even or
not, the intensity
may be zero.
These are rules for systematic
absences.
And the corresponding
information is given for you
here for these not terribly
realistic real
two-dimensional crystals.
So, for example, if you turn to
number seven, P2MG, it says
conditions limiting possible
reflections
for the general position.
For H and K, there's
no condition.
For H zero, H has to be even,
if the reflection is to have
non-zero intensity.
And for the last two, for the
general reflections, H, K, if
there's an atom occupying the
position either zero, zero or
the position zero, one half,
then for the general planes
with indices H, K, you will
see intensity only if H is
even, as well-- same as
the condition above.
This is something that is not
generally known that everybody
knows-- that if the crystal is
face-centered cubic, there is
a pattern of absences.
But there are additional
absences if the atom is in a
special position.
And this can very often be used
to advantage because you
can single out certain classes
of Miller indices for which
one atom in the structure will
not diffract or which another
atom in the structure
will not diffract.
And that can be of
great utility in
unraveling a structure.
We'll see some examples of this
in useful form when we
deal with three-dimensional
space groups.
And the corresponding sheets
for the three-dimensional
symmetries will be handed
out to you-- some of
them, not all of them.
Let me take a little bit of time
to remind you, if you've
forgotten them, but to inform
you of certain definitions and
trigonometry in spherical
geometry.
Spherical trigonometry differs
from plane geometry in that
all of the action takes place
on the surface of a sphere.
And it'd be nice if I had
a spherical blackboard.
Actually there is one in the
x-ray laboratory that I can
draw things right on that
spherical surface.
But this is a sphere.
We'll see directly that
the radius of the
sphere is not important.
So we'll take that as a unity,
which is a nice, even number.
And as my dichotomy of the
afternoon, if we pass a plane
through that sphere, if the
plane hits the sphere, it will
intersect it in a circle.
If the plane passes through
the center of the sphere--
and we've assigned the radius
of the sphere as unity, then
this is a circle that's referred
to a great circle.
Sounds like a value judgment,
but it's simply saying that's
as large as the circle is going
to get is when it passes
through the center of the
sphere., it would have unit
radius, just as the
sphere does.
So if you take any other plane
which intersects the sphere
but doesn't pass through the
center, it's going to have a
smaller radius.
And this is something that's
called a small circle.
OK, so if all of the action is
going to take place on the
surface of the sphere, and we
have two points on the sphere,
A and B, sitting on the surface
of the sphere, how do
we measure the separation
of A and B?
Well, if you think in terms of
a normal three-dimensional
person, you say, zonk, connect
them by a line.
And that's the distance between
A and B. Now, you
can't do that because all the
action has to take place on
the surface of the sphere.
People who deal with spherical
trigonometry all the time are
airplane pilots.
And if your pilot is going to
take you from New York--
where would you like to go?
Paris?
That sounds like a nice place.
But if you're going to go from
New York to Paris, you don't
plow your way through the
intervening earth.
You follow something that is at
a constant radius out from
the center the Earth, at a
height of 5,000 feet above the
surface of the Earth, an
additional radius.
So the way we'll define distance
is to pass a great
circle through A, B, pass a
plane through A, B in the
center of the sphere.
And then we will define distance
between A and B as
the smaller of the two angles
subtended at the
center of the sphere.
So this is a more reasonable
looking great circle.
If this is point A and this is
point B, pass a plane through
the center of the sphere, O, and
through A and through B.
And then we'll measure the
length of the arc AB in terms
of the angle alpha subtended at
the center of the sphere.
So it's a crazy notion.
We're measuring distance
in terms of an angle.
And if that's an angle, we can
take a trigonometric function
of that angle, like
sine or cosine.
And that blows the mind that
you can take trigonometric
functions of a distance.
But we can.
We'll see it's going to
be useful to us, too.
And then I emphasize again,
we'll take this
as the smaller distance.
It'll be 360 degrees
minus alpha.
That would be the
long way around
from A to B. All right.
We've defined now
how we will draw
distances between two points.
Suppose I have three points on
the surface of the sphere--
A, B, and C. I can pass a great
circle through A and B.
I know how to do that.
I can pass a great circle
through A and C. I
know how to do that.
And I can pass a great circle
through B and C.
So now I have defined something
that is referred to
as a spherical triangle.
We know how to measure
the length of
the spherical triangle.
Let's call the arc opposite the
point of intersection A as
little a and the length of the
arc opposite B as a distance
and angles little b, and
the distance from A
to C as little c.
But there's something in between
these arcs that looks
like an angle analogous to the
angle in a planar triangle.
And how can we define that?
Well, the arc AB is defined by
a plane, a great circle.
The arc AC is similarly defined
by a plane that passes
through a, c in the center
of the sphere.
And what we will define as the
spherical angle BAC is the
angle between the great circles
that define the two
different arcs.
So if there's one great circle
that defines the arc from A to
B and another plane that defines
the arc from A to C,
we'll define as the spherical
angle between those two arcs
the angle between the planes
that define the great circles.
So we're going to call this
angle in here between these
two planes as angle BAC.
Another construct that
is a useful one--
suppose I look at the plane
that I've used to define a
great circle and at the center
of the sphere construct a line
that is perpendicular
to the great circle.
And if I extend that line,
sooner or later it's going to
poke out through the surface
of the sphere.
And I will refer to this point
as the pole of arc AB, or the
pole of the great circle that
we've used to define arc AB.
So the North Pole is actually
the pole of the great circle
that defines the equator.
And clearly there
are two poles.
There's one in either
direction.
So there's a North Pole and a
South Pole to this arc AB and
to the great circle
that defines it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question.
Why couldn't you define the
angle BAC as the angle
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You want to
make a tangent here?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: I don't know if
that's really defined.
In other words, if I'm saying I
want a line that is tangent
to the sphere, it doesn't
fix its orientation.
AUDIENCE: In the plane
of the great circle.
PROFESSOR: OK.
In the plane of the
great circle.
Suppose you could if
you wanted to.
There are trigonometric
qualities to defining the
angle in the way that we have.
And the construct really is not
something confined to the
surface of the sphere, and
everything else that
we are doing is.
OK?
So it's sort of the non sequitur
because we started
out by saying that everything
has to take place on the
surface of the sphere.
There's things that we would
do in our three-dimensional
world, like defining distances
between points as the shortest
straight line, that are ruled
out in spherical trigonometry.
And I think something
similar could be
levied at your proposal.
And the answer is we just
don't do it that way.
That's the real answer.
OK.
If I have not boggled your mind
so far, let me go a bit
further with another
useful construct.
We can see how we can define a
pole of a great circle or a
pole on an arc that is a portion
of a great circle.
Let me take a spherical
triangle, A, B, and C. And
I've got three great circles
now, which have formed those
arcs that make up the sides
of my triangle.
Let me now find the
pole of arc CB.
And that means we're going to
go out 90 degrees to that
plane through the center
of the sphere.
And that's going to define some
point that I'll call A
prime, that is the
pole of arc BC.
And I'm going to do the same
thing for the other arcs that
are sides of my great circle
of my spherical triangle.
I'll find the pole of arc AC.
And I'm going to label that
point as B prime.
And, finally, there'll be
another pole that is
the pole of arc AB.
And that's going to define
a point C prime.
Now I've got three points, I can
connect these together and
make another spherical
triangle.
AUDIENCE: How do you know to
determine where the pole is?
PROFESSOR: If you think of it
in three dimensions, I got
three different arcs.
And for each one of them I am
drawing a perpendicular to the
plane of that great circle
and looking at the
point where it emerges.
OK.
So now if there's another arc,
there'll be another great
circle coming around
like this.
And I look for the pole of it.
And that would be another
one of the corners.
This thing that I've constructed
is bizarre.
But it's given a special name.
This is called the
polar triangle.
And it has some useful
properties.
A property of the polar triangle
is that the two
triangles, A, B, and C, and A
prime, B prime, and C prime
are mutually polar.
That is, if I use the spherical
triangle ABC to
define and locate the
three points A
prime, B prime, C prime--
now if I reverse the process
and find the whole of arc A
prime C prime, that turns
out to be point B.
And if I take the arc of A prime
B prime, that turns--
I'm sorry-- take the arc of B
prime C prime, that turns out
to be point A. So the two
triangles are mutually polar.
The polar triangle of the polar
triangle is the triangle
that we started with.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I guess
I missed that.
So if you take B prime
through C prime, then
all of that is going--
PROFESSOR: Yeah, I'm saying that
the pole of this arc, A
prime C prime, is
this point here.
And the way I can show that
is to say that we got B by
looking at the pole--
I'm sorry--
I got C by looking at the
pole of the arc AB.
So B is 90 degrees away
from C prime.
I found point A prime by finding
the pole of arc CB.
So B is 90 degrees from
any point on that arc.
So it's 90 degrees away
from A. So B is 90
degrees from A prime.
B is 90 degrees C prime.
And, therefore, it has to
be the pole of that arc.
Now that was a little
too quick.
That's written down
in the notes.
And that's why I
wrote them out.
One final thing and then we can
put circle trigonometry to
one side, and this is something
that is not all obvious.
If we look at a spherical
triangle and simultaneously
the polar triangle--
so let's say this is ABC.
And here is the polar triangle
A prime, C prime, B prime.
It turns out that the spherical
angle in one circle
triangle and the length of the
arc opposite it, namely this
arc B prime C prime,
are complementary--
supplementary, not
complementary.
And the way one would do that is
to say that the measure of
alpha is the length
of this arc here.
And this total side, B prime C
prime, is equal to this arc
plus this arc minus
this length.
And these two arcs
are 90 degrees.
So let me do as I've
done in the notes.
Let me call this
point P prime.
And I'll call this
point Q prime.
So my argument, it says that B
prime is the pole of arc AC.
And, therefore, B prime
Q prime equals
90 degrees in length.
And then I would say that C
prime is the pole of arc AB.
And, therefore, the distance C
prime P prime is also exactly
90 degrees.
And that says that B prime Q
prime plus C prime P prime--
if I add those two together,
it has to be 180 degrees.
But I can write B prime C prime
as B prime P prime plus
P prime Q prime plus Q prime
C prime plus the
side P prime Q prime.
And that's 180 degrees.
But these three things that I've
lumped together here are
exactly the same as the length
of the spherical polar
triangle A prime.
So what we've shown then is
that A prime plus alpha is
equal to 180 degrees--
QED.
So this angle plus the side of
the polar triangle add up to
180 degrees.
And that is not obvious
at all.
One final relation--
and this I will simply hand
to you on a platter.
I'm not about to derive it.
Sides and angles in planar
geometry are related.
And there's a particularly
useful relation in plane
geometry that's called
the Law of Cosines.
So this is in plane geometry.
And if you have a triangle
that has sides a, b, c--
a general oblique triangle--
and it has angles A, B, and C,
the Law of Cosines says that
the side A is determined
by c and b and the
angle between them.
And that's clear.
If I specify this length,
specify this length, specify
that angle, things set up like
a bowl of supercooled jello.
And the triangle's completely
specified.
So a squared in the Law of
Cosines is b squared plus c
squared minus 2bc times
the cosine of angle A.
In a spherical triangle there
is a similar sort of
constraint.
If we have a spherical triangle
with sides a, b, and
c, and spherical angles capital
A, capital B, capital
C, in the same way as specifying
the spherical angle
A and the lengths of the two
sides c and b, specifies and
fixes the spherical
triangle entirely.
This side must be determined by
the length of side c, the
length of side b, and the
angle between them.
And that, since everything
is in terms of angles, is
something that doesn't
involve squares.
It involves totally
trigonometric expressions.
And it turns out the cosine of
this missing side a is given
by the product of the cosines
of the two other sides.
So as I said, you can take a
trigonometric function of a
length, which sounds
like an oxymoron.
And it's the product of the
cosines of the two known sides
and times the sine of b sine of
c times the cosine of the
spherical angle A.
And that is also
called the Law of Cosines.
And this is the corresponding
case in spherical geometry.
OK.
So there's some machinery--
yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: What's the difference
between the sines
of lowercase a and--
PROFESSOR: OK, the angles
are the capital letters.
This would be the angle between
the great circles that
defines the--
AUDIENCE: Since the radius is
one, there's no difference
between the angles and the--
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
This angle is something, for
example, we can choose.
And depending on how long we
want this arc to be, we can
put the arc BC anywhere
we like.
AUDIENCE: Does that mean your
radius [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: No.
This would be, say, two points
of the spherical triangle.
Now we can pick any third point
on the surface of the
sphere, connect that with great
circles, and here is a
spherical triangle.
OK?
So I see.
I think I see what
your problem is.
Here are the two planes.
We define the angle of the
spherical triangle as the
angle subtended buy
the great circle.
So this is the definition
of A.
But now the other two points on
the spherical triangle can
be any point on these
great circles.
So this can be point B, and this
can be point C. And my
spherical triangle can be
something like this.
So the arc that defines the
spherical angle A is a value
that is independent from the
length of the arc AC.
That would be what is
subtended at the
center of the sphere.
I'm going to have time just to
set the stage for how we're
going to use these relations.
And the problem that I would
like to raise and then apply
spherical trigonometry to is
the question if I go into
three-dimensional space, there
is no longer any requirement
that rotation axes be all
parallel to the same direction.
In two dimensions the rotation
points were really--
could be viewed as axes that
were always perpendicular to
the plane of the blackboard, the
plane of the plane group.
But now when I'm dealing with
three-dimensional spaces, this
could be the operation
A alpha.
And there is no reason
whatsoever why we should not
try to combine with this
first operation a
second rotation B beta--
a rotation through an angle beta
about this axis B and a
rotation of angle alpha through
this axis A. If we're
going to come up with a
crystallographic combination,
the angles alpha and beta have
to be restricted to the
angular rotations of either
a onefold, a twofold, a
threefold, a fourfold, or
a sixfold axis, if the
combination is going to
be crystallographic.
Yes, sir?
AUDIENCE: You're just rotating
around those lines?
PROFESSOR: I'm rotating around
those lines, yeah.
So I'm saying that we're going
to rotate an angle alpha about
axis A.
And now what I'm going
to raise as
a rhetorical question--
what is the rotation A alpha
followed by B beta?
So I rotate through the angle
alpha about A. So here's my
first motif, right-handed.
Then I'll rotate
alpha degrees.
And this here's number two.
And that will stay
right-handed.
Now, I will place on axis
B the two constraints.
These have to be
crystallographic rotation
angles, namely 360, 180,
120, 90, or 60.
And I'll also, since I would
like to obtain point group
symmetries initially, I will
require that axis A and axis B
intersect at some point.
And one of the variables in the
combination will be this
angle between the two
rotation axes.
So let's complete our
combination of operations.
I'll rotate from one
to two by A alpha.
If the first one is
right-handed, the second motif
is right-handed, as well.
And then I will rotate beta
degrees about B. And here will
sit number three.
And it will stay right-handed.
So, again, the $64 question that
we raise periodically--
what operation is the net
effect of two successive
rotations about a point
of intersection?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
PROFESSOR: Lots of opinions.
Let's sort them out.
I heard translation.
Well, let's put down
what it could be.
We know that only translation
and rotation leaves the
chirality of the motif
unchanged.
So it's got to be one
or the other.
AUDIENCE: Since there's no
reason for the general
orientation of the two to say
it has to be rotation around
the third axis, so
the question is
what angle and what--
PROFESSOR: OK.
That is exactly the problem.
Now that we know the problem,
we can go home early because
we know what we're going
to do next time.
Well, let me expand
a little bit.
It can't be translation because
clearly the separation
of number one and number three
depend on exactly where I
place the first one.
If I place it a little further
out from A, then it's going to
rotate to here.
And then B is going
to swing it off to
some different location.
So it can't be translation.
And I don't think these guys, if
I rotate this way and then
I rotate this way, are going to
be parallel to one another.
I doubt that very much.
So it's got to be a rotation.
So without knowing how to find
it, let's say that we can get
from number one to number three
in one shot through
rotation of an angle gamma about
some third axis, C. So
the answer, in general, without
being specific, is A
alpha followed B beta has got
to be equal to a third
rotation, C, about a direction
that has the same point of
intersection with the
first two axes.
Now we've got some really,
really tough constraints.
Alpha is restricted to
one of five values.
Beta is restricted to
The third rotation, gamma,
jolly well better be a
crystallographic rotation and
not something that is not a
sub-multiple of 2 pi.
And even if it is a sub-multiple
of 2 pi, it has
to be either 0 degrees,
120, so on.
It has to be one of the
crystallographic rotation angles.
So what sort of relation can
we get that would give us,
first, the value of gamma in
terms of alpha, beta, and the
angle at which we
combine them?
So taking A and B as the five
crystallographic rotation axes
two at a time, we want to put
them together, if we can, such
that the angle makes the third
rotation axis also be
crystallographic.
And then we would have
to find its location.
It looks like an impossible
constraint .
It looks absolutely
impossible to do.
We've got to put this first in
quantitative form and then
simply put in the values for
alpha, beta, and gamma and
find the angle that they have
to be combined on to make
this, if possible, be one
of the crystallographics
sub-multiples.
That is not an easy problem
to formulate.
And, as I said a couple of times
ago, the geometry that
is the basis of this derivation
was originally
proposed by Euler.
And it's known as Euler's
Construction.
I will have for you next time
my own set of notes on this.
We have finished with
two-dimensional
crystallography.
So we are back to Buerger's
book again.
We had that little interlude.
Buerger deals with Euler's
Construction.
But I don't think he's
at his best in
this particular section.
So we'll take it a little
more slowly.
And next time we'll get around
to deriving Euler's
Construction.